HttpURLConnection is one HTTP client
that you can use to make
HTTP requests in Android.
Now, you can also use
third-party libraries that
weren't created by Google.
For example, OKHttp is a popular
open-source HTTP client
created by
the Square Mobile Payments Company.
They've done a lot of
open-source work for Android.
This class helps you send and
receive data across the web
using an HTTP connection.
Once you have a URL,
actually opening up an HTTP connection
is actually pretty straightforward.
You start by calling url.openConnection.
Then to actually fire
off the connection, and
be ready to return results, you go ahead
and you specify the RequestMethod.
In this case,
we're going to use the GET HTTP method.
Then, you go ahead and call Connect and
then finally, you call getInputStream
on your connection which is going to be
the input stream containing the results.
Now, despite the of
the codes that you see here,
the Android platform is actually
handling many of the complex networking
details on to the hood for you.
In other words, Android as an operating
system is actually working with your
device's hardware to setup connection
and handled some of the physical steps
that need to happen in order for
the communication to work.